the idea that people somehow feel
comfortable enough to cheer and laugh
when Donald Trump is mocking somebody by
calling them Pocahontas right Pocahontas
you know I mean I had to be totally
honest with you not to be until it corny
that makes me want to cry you know I
mean it because we're gonna get the
leaders in this life that we deserve and
if we walk around and we think that
stuff is funny you know what people I
think admire about Trump is that he's
willing to say an off-color thing and I
understand what people mean by that that
we live in a culture where what's the
right member of Martin Luther King said
I prefer the racist because I know where
he stands what I don't like is all the
quiet people who might be secret I can't
I can't work with somebody who's
secretly racist right and so in a way
bring it out Donald Trump bring it out
bring out all the toxic stuff let's
everybody and really make sure you want
to cheer for that really make sure you
think that's funny really study who
Pocahontas was and you really think
that's not something to be proud of I
mean I'd be honored if somebody would
call me Pocahontas
you know if our elected officials aren't
you know demanding ethical higher ground
then we're in a very dangerous place and
if I find that kind of jingoistic hate
talk to be terrifying because it's
always history shows it's always an easy
way whenever we're upset and whenever
we're angry if somebody gives us a
chance to express our anger it feels
good temporarily it does you know it
when the two towers fall if you want to
start making anti-arab sentiments for a
second it feels good because it feels
like a place to put your rage um what it
usually does is you know create a cycle
of violence a large percentage of the
people that I know that support the
unmentionable game show hosts running
for president what they admire about him
is that he doesn't seemed chained to
some kind of political correctness and
it makes him seem like a maverick and it
makes it immediately gives some kind of
swagger to the whole thing
because most of us live in such fear of
saying the wrong thing I remember I had
the great but if I got to interview Kris
Kristofferson the great poet songwriter
actor and I was asking him what happened
to the tough guy liberal like why are
all liberals now kind of seen as you
know kind of like somehow were lesser
men then like kind of the the hardcore
hate talk like why does that somehow why
is that equated with masculinity we're
in his generation you know he and Johnny
Cash and you know my grandfather LBJ
there was a great you know the Southern
progressive you know the the person who
really walked the walk and talk the talk
of the unwavering equality of mankind
where did that guy go and Chris talked
about something that really bothered him
at Johnny Cash used to say you want to
say people ask me you know they ask me
mama Dover or Hawke and I say I'm a dove
with claws and and then and Chris used
to say you know sure I want it kept I
always wanted to say to Johnny you know
no one thinks you're a you can
just say you're a dove you know a dove
doesn't have claws and it's okay to say
I'll fight to the death for the right
for people to be free for people to
speak their mind for people to treat
each other with mutual respect that I
will die for you know I'll fight for the
death to save this planet I'll stand for
something but you don't have to be a
dove with claws aa fight for the doves
you know a fight for them so that they
can live and so I really always
respected Chris for that and I long for
that kind of an integrity you know and
for that kind of free speech
you